well let's
uh talk about the probably
the most interesting object i've heard
about and also the most fun to pronounce
can you tell me the story of uh this
object and why it may be
an important event in human history and
is it possibly a piece of alien
technology
right so um this is the first object
that was spotted
close to earth from outside the solar
system
and it was found in on october 19
2017 and at that time it was receding
away from us
and at first astronomers thought it must
be a piece of rock you know just like
all the asteroids and comets that we
have seen from within the solar system
and it just came from another star i
should say that the actual discovery of
this object was surprising to
me because a decade earlier i wrote the
first paper together with
ed turner and amaya mauro martin that
tried to predict whether the same
telescope that was serving the sky
pan stars from hawaii would find
anything
from interstellar space given what we
know about the solar system so if you
assume that other
planetary systems have similar abundance
of rocks and you just calculate
how many should be ejected into
interstellar space
the conclusion is no it we shouldn't
find anything with
pan stars to me i apologize probably
revealing my stupidity but
it was surprising to me that so few
interstellar objects
from outside this whole system have ever
been
detected or not none has been you you do
well maybe talk about it that there has
been uh
uh one or two rocks since then well
since then there was one
uh called the borisov it was discovered
by
an amateur russian astronomer yeah uh
gennady borisov
and that one looked like a comet
yep and uh just like a comet from within
the solar system but this is a really
important point sorry to interrupt that
you showed that it's unlikely that a
rock from another solar system
would arrive to ours right and so the
actual detection of this one was
surprising by itself
to me yes um and then
but then so at first they thought maybe
it's a comet or an asteroid but then it
look it didn't look like anything we've
seen before
borisov did look like a comet so people
asked me afterwards and said
you know doesn't it convince you if
borisov
looks like a comet doesn't he convince
you that umuah is also natural
and i said you know when i went on the
first date with my wife
she looked special to me yes and since
then i met many women
yes that didn't change my opinion of my
life so you know that's not an argument
anyway so why did why did the
omua muah look weird let me explain
so first of all astronomers monitored
the amount of light
sunlight that it reflects and it was
tumbling
spinning every eight hours and as it was
spinning
the brightness that we saw from that
direction we couldn't resolve it because
it's tiny it's
about 100 meters a few hundred feet size
of a football field
and we cannot from earth with existing
telescopes
we cannot resolve it the only way to
actually get a photograph of it
is to send the camera close to it
and that was not possible at the time
that um was discovered because it was
already moving away from us faster than
any rocket we can send
it's sort of like a guest that appeared
for dinner
and then by the time we realized that
it's weird uh the guest is already out
the front door into the dark street
yeah what we would like to find is an
object like it
approaching us because then you can send
the camera irrespective of how fast it
moves
and if we were to find it in july 2017
that would have been possible because it
was approaching us at that time
actually i was visiting mount haleakala
in maui hawaii with my family for
vacation at that time in july 2017
but nobody knew uh
at the observatory that um
is very close that's sad to think about
that we had the opportunity at that time
yes to send up a camera but don't worry
i mean there will be more there will be
more because
you know i i operate by the copernican
principle which says we don't live at a
special place
and we don't live at a special time and
that means
you know if we surveyed the sky for a
few years
and we had sensitivity to this region
between us and the sun
and we found this object with pan stars
you know there should be many more that
we will find in the future
with surveys that might be even better
yes uh and
actually in three years time scale there
would be
the so-called lsst that's a survey of
the vera rubin observatory
that would be much more sensitive and
could potentially find
an umura like object every month
okay so wow i'm just waiting for that
and the main reason for me to alert
everyone to the unusual properties of
umuah
is with the hope that next time around
when we see something
as unusual we would take a photograph or
we would get as much evidence as
possible
because science is based on evidence not
on prejudice and we will get back to
that theme
so anyway let me let me point out some
of the properties actually yeah
the elongated nature all right other
things so uh
the light curve the amount of light
sunlight that was reflected from it
was changing over 8 hours by a factor of
meaning that the area of this object
even though we can't resolve it
the area on the sky that reflects
sunlight
was bigger by a factor of 10
in some phases as it was tumbling around
than in other phases so
even if you take a piece of paper that
is razor thin
you know it's there is a very small
likelihood that it's exactly edge-on
uh and getting a factor of 10 change in
the area that you see on the sky
is huge it's much more than any it means
that the object has
an unusual geometry it's at least a
factor of a few more than any of the
comets or asteroids that we have seen
before
you mentioned reflectivity so it's not
just the geometry but
the the properties of the surface of
that thing well
uh or no if you assume the reflectivity
is the same
okay then it's just geometry if you
assume the reflectivity may change
yes then it could be a combination of
the area that you see and the
reflectivity because
different directions may reflect
differently but the point is that it's
very extreme
yes and it actually the best fit
to the light curve that we saw was of a
flat object
unlike all the cartoons that you have
seen
of a cigar shape a flat object at the 90
percent confidence gives
a better model for the way that the
light varied
and it's like flat meaning like a
pancake like a pancake
exactly uh and so that's the you know
the very first unusual property but to
me it was not unusual enough to think
that it might be
artificial it was not significant enough
then
there was no cometary tail you know no
dust
no gas around this object and the
spitzer space telescope
really searched very deeply for
carbon-based molecules
there was nothing so it's definitely not
a comet the way people expected it to be
can you maybe briefly mention what uh
properties a comet
that you're referring to usually has
right so a comet
is a rock that has some water ice on the
surface
so you can think of it as an icy rock
actually comets were discovered a long
time ago but
the first model uh that was uh developed
for for them was by fred the whipple who
was at harvard
and i think the legend goes that he got
the idea from walking through
harvard square and seeing uh during a
winter day and seeing these icy rocks
you know and so a comet is icy
and this is an asteroid is uh it's just
a rock
it's just a wrap yeah so when you have
ice on the surface
when the rock gets close to the sun the
sunlight warms it up
and the the ice sublimates evaporates
because the one thing about ice water
ice
is it doesn't become liquid if you warm
it up
in vacuum you know without an external
pressure
it just goes straight into gas and
that's what you see as the
tail of a comet the only way to get
liquid water is to have an atmosphere
like on earth that has an external
pressure
only then you get liquid and that's why
it's essential to have an atmosphere to
a planet
in order to have liquid water and the
chemistry of life
so if you look at mars mars lost its
atmosphere
and therefore no liquid water on the
surface anymore i mean there may have
been early
and that's what the perseverance uh
survey
you know the perseverance mission we
will try to find out whether
it had liquid water whether there was
life perhaps
on it at the time but at some point it
lost its atmosphere
and then the liquid water was gone so
the only reason that we can live
on earth is because of the atmosphere
but a comet is in vacuum
pretty much and then when it gets warmed
up on the surface
the water becomes the water ice becomes
gas and then you see this cometary tail
behind it
in addition to water there is
that there are all kinds of carbon-based
molecules of dust
that comes off the surface and those are
detectable
it's easy to detect it's very prominent
you see these cometary tails that look
very prominent because they reflect
sunlight
and you can see them in fact it's
sometimes difficult to see the nucleus
of the comet
because it's surrounded and shrouded
with and in this case
there was no trace of anything that's
fast now you might say okay it's not a
com so that's what the community
said okay it's not a no problem it's
still a rock you know it's not a comet
but it's just a rock bare rock you know
okay no problem
then and that's the thing that convinced
me to write about it
and then in june 2018 you know
significantly later
there was a report that in fact the
object
exhibited an excess push
in addition to the force of gravity so
the sun acts on it by gravity
but then there was an extra push on this
object that was
figured out from the orbit that you can
trace
and the question was what is this excess
push
so for comets you get the rocket effect
when you evaporate gas you know just
like a jet engine
on an airplane you throw a jet engine is
very simple you throw the gas back
and it pushes the airplane forward
that's all that's how it get
so in a case of a comet you throw gas in
the direction of the sun because it
and then you get a push okay so in the
case of comets you can get a push
but there was no cometary tail so then
people said
oh wait a second is it an asteroid no
but it behaves like a comet but
it doesn't look like a comet so what it
well
forget about it business as usual so
that's what i mean by a
non-gravitational
non-gravitational acceleration so that's
interesting so
like the the primary force acting on
something like just a rock like an
asteroid
would be like you can predict the
trajectory based on the
based on gravity and also here there's
detected movement that's
not cannot be accounted purely by the
gravity so if it was a comet
you would need about a tenth of
the mass of this comet the weight of
this government to be evaporated in
order to give it and there's no sign of
that no sign
ten percent of the mass evaporating it's
huge
think about it a hundred meter size
object losing 10 percent of its mass
you can't miss that and uh so that's
super weird
it's super weird what is there a good
explanation in your mind and possible
explanations for this you know so i
operated just like sherlock holmes in a
way
i said okay what are the possibilities
and the only thing i could think
so i ruled out everything else and i i
said it must be the sunlight
reflected off it okay so the sunlight
reflects off the surface and gives it a
push
just like you get a push on a sail on a
boat you know from the wind reflecting
off it
now in order for this to be effective it
turns out the object needs to be
extremely thin
uh it turns out it needs to be less than
a millimeter thick
nature does not produce such things so
but
we produce it because it's called the
technology of a light sail
so we are for space exploration we are
exploring this technology because
it it has the benefit of not needing to
carry the fuel
with the spacecraft so you don't have
the fuel you just have a
you just have a sail and it's being
pushed either by sunlight
or by a laser beam or whatever uh
so perhaps this is the light sail so
this is
actually the same technology with the
with the starshot project yes
so that's fascinating okay people
afterwards say okay you work on this
project you imagine
you know no that's a pretty good
explanation right obviously my
imagination is limited by what i know
so i you know i would not deny that you
know
working on light sales expanded my
ability to imagine this possibility yes
but let me offer another interesting
anecdote
in september this year 2020 i mean yes
2020 yes there was
another object found and it was given
the name
2020 so by the minor
planet center you know this is an
organization actually
in cambridge massachusetts that gives
names
to objects astronomical objects found in
the solar system and
they gave it that name 2020 so because
you know it looked like
uh an object in the solar system and
it moved in an orbit that is similar to
the orbit of the earth
but not the same exactly and therefore
it was bound to the sun
but it also exhibited a deviation from
what you expect based on gravity
so the astronomers that found it
extrapolated back in time and found that
in 1966 it
intercepted the earth and then they
realized they went to the history books
and they realized oh there was a mission
called gruner surveyor lunar lander
surveyor 2 that had a rocket booster it
was a failed mission but
uh there was a rocket booster that was
kicked into space
and presumably this is the rocket
booster that we're seeing now
this rocket booster was sufficiently
hollow and thin
for us to recognize that it's pushed by
sunlight
so here is my point we can tell from the
orbit of an object obviously this object
didn't have any cometary tail
it was artificially made we know that it
was made by
us and it did deviate from an orbit
of a rock so just by seeing something
that doesn't have cometary tail and
deviates from an orbit shaped by gravity
we can tell that it's artificial in the
case of umuamua
it couldn't have been sent by humans
because it just
passed near us for a few months we know
exactly what we were doing at those
times
at that time and also it was moving
faster than any object that we can
launch
and so obviously it came from outside
the solar system
and the question is who produced it now
i should say that you know when i walk
on vacation on a beach i often see
natural
objects like seashells that are
beautiful and i look at them and
um and every now and then i stumble on a
plastic bottle
and that was artificially produced
and my point is that maybe omuamua was a
message in a bottle
and we should see this is simply another
window into searching
for artifacts from other civilizations
where do you think
it could have come from and
if it's so okay from a scientific
perspective
the narrow-minded view as we'll probably
talk about throughout is you know you
kind of want to stick to the things that
uh
to naturally originating objects like
asteroids and comets
okay that's the space of possible
hypotheses and then if we expand beyond
that
you start to think okay these are
artificially constructed like you just
said it could be by humans
it could be by uh by
whatever that means by some kind of
extraterrestrial alien
civilizations if if it's the alien
civilization
variety what is this object
then an excellent question and
let me lay out i mean we don't have
enough evidence to tell
if we had a photograph perhaps we would
have more information but
the possib there is one other peculiar
fact about omuamua
well other than it was very shiny that i
didn't mention
you know we didn't detect any heat from
it and that implies that it's rather
small
and shiny but the other particular fact
is that it was
it came from a very special frame of
reference
so it's sort of like finding a car in a
parking lot in a public parking lot
that you know you can't really tell
where it came from
so there is this frame of reference
where you average
over the motions of all the stars in the
neighborhood of the sun
so um you find the so-called local
standard of
rest of the galaxy and that's uh
a frame of reference that is obtained by
averaging the random motions of all the
stars and
the sun is moving relative to that frame
at some speed
but this object was at rest in that
frame and only one in 500 stars
is so much at rest in that frame and
that's why i was saying it's like a
parking lot it was
parked there and we bumped into it so
the relative speed between the solar
system
and this object is just because we are
moving
it was sitting still now you ask
yourself why is it so
unusual in that context you know why
because if it was
expelled from another planetary system
most likely
it will carry the speed of the host star
that it came from because it was you
know the most loosely bound objects are
in the periphery
of the planetary system and they move
very slowly relative to the star and so
they carry the
when they are ripped apart from the
planetary system most of the objects
will have
the residual motion of the star roughly
relative to the local stuff
but this one was at rest in the locals
now one thing i can think of if if there
is a grid
of uh road posts you know like for
navigation system
so that you can find your way in the
local frame yeah
then that would be one position these
are like little sensors
of that's fascinating to think about so
there could be i mean not
necessarily literally a grid but just uh
evenly in some definition of evenly
spread out
set of objects like these right that are
just out there
a lot of them another possibility is
that these are relay stations you know
that for communication
you might think in order to communicate
you need a huge beacon
yeah a very powerful beacon but it's not
true because even on earth you know we
have these relay stations so you have
a not so powerful beacon so it can be
heard only out to a limited distance but
then
you relay the message yes and it could
be one of those
now after it collided with this the
solar system of course it got a kick so
it's just like a
billiard ball you know we gave it a a
kick by colliding with
but most of them are not colliding with
stars and so that's one possibility
okay and there should be numer lots of
them if that's the case
um the other possibility
is that it's a probe you know that was
sent
uh in the direction of the um
habitable region around the sun to find
out if there is life
now it takes tens of thousands of years
for such a probe to traverse the solar
system from the outer edge of the old
cloud
all the way to where we are and you know
it's a long journey so when it started
the journey from the edge of the solar
system to get to us now
you know we were rather primitive back
then you know we we still didn't have
any technology there was
no reason to visit you know there was
grass around and so forth
but you know maybe it is a problem uh so
you said 10
000 years as fast so it takes that long
tens of thousands
yes tens of thousands a year yeah yeah
and
uh the other thing i should say is you
know it could be just
a a an outer layer of something else
like
you know something that was ripped apart
like a surface of
an instrument that was and and you can
have lots of these pieces you know if
something breaks
lots of these pieces spread out like
space junk and
you know that it could be just space
junk
from an extra from an alien civilization
yes
you